this video is made possible by Nord vbn
start protecting your internet
experience today go to Nord VPN comm
slash visual politic to get 75% off a
three-year plan plus an extra month for
free with the code visual politic ships
loaded with giant treasures adventurers
faring the seven seas black flags with
skulls and crossbones ferocious Corps
says with eye patches and wooden legs
legends are giving goosebumps like those
of Blackbeard Francis Drake and Henry
Morgan
pirates filibusters Buccaneers Corsairs
who for centuries conquered the seas in
search of gold silver and precious
stones tell me who didn't grow up
knowing at least one story about fierce
intrepid and daring pirates from the
legends of Blackbeard's hoop novels like
Treasure Island modern cinema characters
like Captain Jack Sparrow throughout
mankind's history pirates have been a
source of fascination admiration or
terror but don't think for a moment that
they disappeared was a no longer fought
only on land sea and air these days they
are increasingly fought in cyberspace
that probably doesn't come there's any
surprise to you the country can greatly
harm another simply by attacking as
computer systems imagine everything they
could do lock communication and
transport systems electrical equipment
financial systems I mean practically
everything nowadays because everything
involves computers this is something
that practically all countries know
including North Korea
yes you heard that correctly and if you
don't believe me well let me try and
convince you in recent years the most
secretive hermetic country on the planet
has not only been developing an arsenal
of nuclear weapons
it has also mounted its very own hacking
offensive you see a 1998 Kim Jong Il
former North Korean leader and father of
the current leader Kim jong-un set up
what is known as unit 121 a cyber
warfare core that he claimed was made up
of thousands of people who work morning
noon and night getting ready to sow
chaos through cyber attacks against
communication networks energy grids and
all kinds of strategic infrastructure
belonging to the enemies of Pyongyang
yes it may seem a strange claim and
quite a paradox coming from one of the
most hermetic and poorest regimes in the
world but this country was highly
restricted Internet access and where the
government has developed its own
internet a kind of rough and highly
guarded intranet it has one of the most
dangerous hacker armies in all of
cyberspace for them the strongest weapon
is cyber in North Korea it's called the
secret war incentives for North Korea's
cyber experts are very attractive
they're rich people in Pyongyang Jiang
say ëwell a former student of North
Korea's military college for computer
science folks the person who declared
this to Reuters Yangtze Yul is a young
North Korean who before escaping to
South Korea used to study side-by-side
with people who now belong to unit 121
his testimony corroborates what many
experts have been arguing about for
years cyber warfare units are a priority
for the North Korean regime in fact
hyuna's 121 depends on the General
Directorate of acknowledgments and
intelligence agency the reports and
responds directly to Kim Jong himself
and that's not all according to some
estimations these cyberattack teams are
composed of almost 2,000 hackers and
maybe costing between 10 and 20 percent
of the entire North Korean military
budget this is a pretty good indication
of how important they are to the country
it is believed that they launched their
first large attack in 2013 using malware
known as Dark Soul these hacker teams
managed to arrays a huge amount of data
and block or turn off 32,000 devices in
South Korea devices which included the
servers of four major banks and three
South Korean television agencies and I
promise you this is not a joke just one
year later in 2014 South Korea's nuclear
energy corporation announced that their
computer systems have been hacked the
North Korean hackers had stolen plans
for their nuclear reactors personal data
on more than 10,000 employees and other
undisclosed information since then the
attacks that North Korean hackers have
carried out around the globe have been
continuous and quite a headache for
several international companies and
governments
for example in 2017 the same guys
working under Kim jong-un service
launched the virus wanna cry which
became the largest malicious software
attack in history it is estimated that
it affected more than 300,000 devices
and put multinationals such as FedEx and
telefónica
on the ropes the US and UK governments
have said North Korea was responsible
for the wanna cry malware attack
affecting hospitals businesses and banks
across the world one important detail
these hackers don't only operate from
North Korea once they've been trained
many of these hackers are sent to China
Southeast Asia or other countries under
false identities so that they can act
from they're surprised well listen up
because North Korea has another cyber
warfare units that might amaze you even
more
unit 180 attack on the Treasury let's
face it North Korea has never exactly
done well in the international arena
however since Kim jong-un came to power
in 2011 accelerated the North Korean
nuclear program sanctions against the
country have multiplied and folks
developing a nuclear and ballistic
program it's not exactly cheap so the
question is if international sanctions
cut you off and prevent you from trading
with the rest of the world then the hell
are you gonna do to get money that you
need to continue buying everything you
need on the black markets in order to
complete your nuclear program any ideas
folks this question was on Kim Jong Un's
mind and in his case the answer was unit
180 in 2013 when Kim jong-un had begun
to feel the pressure of international
sanctions he decided to establish what
is known as Yunus 180 with 500
professionals from unit 121 what for
well I was to hack as many bank and
cryptocurrency accounts as possible in
order to obtain the resources he needed
to finance his nuclear and ballistic
program yes you heard that right in 2013
North Korea set up its own cyber crooks
unit this was a huge team dedicated to
stealing money to pay for the wins of
the dear leader unit 180 s primary job
is to gain foreign currency to fund
projects to develop five major weapons
including nuclear bombs long-range
missiles and submarine-launched
ballistic missiles Kim Hyun Kwang
a former computer science teacher at
North Korean University since it was
sent up hyuna's 180 has carried out
numerous acts of theft and dozens and
dozens of robberies all against banks
and cryptocurrency exchanges around the
world in 2016 they even stole over a
hundred million dollars from the Central
Bank of Bangladesh the North Korean
government's desperation for cash is
driving a surge in cyber attacks
targeting banks and other businesses in
the United States and around the world
US officials tell CNN
the North Koreans have quickly become
the world's most advanced and persistent
digital bank robbers it's clear that
global economic penalties are working
and have forced the North Koreans to
turn to alternative approaches to create
revenue anthony Ferrante a former FBI
and White House cyber security official
well in hacking groups depends on you to
180 ins therefore on the North Korean
government's the truth is that North
Korea has taken on the task of being the
bad guy in international politics very
seriously it's got nuclear weapons
hackers it's doing kidnappings and arms
trafficking is there any matter if it's
illegal and it's considered bad Kim
jong-un is all over it now the big
question is how much money have these
North Korean hackers actually been able
to steal well it's not easy to determine
what a panel of experts that reports to
the United Nations Security Council is
estimated that in recent years in
particular since 2016 pyongyang has
accumulated around 670 million u.s.
dollars in foreign currency and
cryptocurrency nearly 700 million
dollars and that's just what we know
about has been stolen by units 180 from
banks and cryptocurrency intermediaries
then they used blockchain to cover their
tracks and to transfer all of this money
to where they need it for example to pay
their technological equipment suppliers
on the black market
they see this is what indicates to us
that the North Korean government is
paying for a large part of its nuclear
program with cryptocurrencies which
obviously harder to track and don't
depend upon international regulations
but stealing is not the only activity
that unit 180 uses to get cash as
they've gained experience unit 180 also
develops software for international
companies especially in Japan and in
China I mean since we're already here
and we have all these hackers who have
intricate knowledge of many complex
cyber systems well I mean might as well
make the most of it right well these
curious orders are coordinated by some
of the pro-north groups that exist
around the world of course you know
hundred eighty offers rather cheap rates
and in many cases that contracting
companies don't even know they are doing
business with North Korean intelligence
and that my friends involves a very high
risk why well because it looks like
these software programs are often full
of backdoors which could eventually
allow the North Korean intelligence
service do control the devices where
this software is installed either to
block them or to continue drawing cash
out of them the software companies unit
180 has set up in countries like Vietnam
and Malaysia are disguised as ordinary
companies and they have provided factory
control systems and other products for
Japanese businesses Fumi Akiyama sake an
information security expert anyway folks
that's the story of how North Korea
managed to develop a powerful cyber
warfare division and use it to advance
their nuclear program
times have really changed we may no
longer be talking about sailing the seas
or pirates with eye patches but we
certainly are talking about piracy all
the same after all the internet it's
basically like a vast ocean now chances
are that your data isn't really that
interesting to North Korea but you know
every day in the press you hear about
the latest hack or data breach not hers
but the good news is that you can
protect yourself with a VPN and that's
where Nord VPN comes in if you have been
sitting in a cafe and on some open Wi-Fi
network and want to check your internet
banking don't think that's a good idea
without a VPN let's say you're a foreign
person living an oppressive dictatorship
with restrictive internet and you want
to watch a fun new treat video like this
one it's all rather met or isn't it
well Nord VPN will sort him out or maybe
more like that you just want to watch a
local content from your own country
abroad they also handle that too Nord
VPN is super fast so watching video is a
breeze there's no lag anything like that
now if you ever used VPNs before and
thought they were slow that is not the
case with Nord VPN and you can use it on
all of your devices very very easily
Android Chrome Windows Linux and you can
use it on six different devices all on
one accounts that's a lot of devices I'm
sure that will cover you
also there are no logs caps at all
unlike companies based in the EU or US
you seek nor the VPN is based in Panama
so they don't have to keep any logs at
all sort of like the opposite of North
Korea isn't it it's amazing for your
privacy indeed they are the only VPN to
get a perfect score from PC Mag go to
Nord VPN comm slash visual politic to
get 75% off a three-year plan plus an
extra month for free with the code
visual politic with a K or click on the
link in the description below and sign
up and start protecting yourself today
again that's noir VPN comm forward slash
visual politic use the code visual
politic at checkout get started today
and thank you for watching and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider Media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there